In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for July 31st, on which we commemorate,
St. Joseph of Arimathea.
The noble and devout Joseph from Arimathea was a member of the Sanhedrin,
the council of the priests and elders of the people of Israel,
but was also a secret disciple of Jesus.
After having received Pilate's authorization,
he took the Lord's body down from the cross and buried it,
helped by Nicodemus in the new tomb that he had had carved in the rock
not far from there.
It is said that he was arrested by the Jews and put in prison
and that the Lord appeared to him to bring him to faith in his resurrection.
Once set free, he went to proclaim the good news of the resurrection
throughout the world, traveling as far as the West.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.